he is the three-point shooting contest
champion this year he's the pride of my
Brooklyn Nancy's Joe Harris who joins us
on the show
Joe how has life changed since she won
the three-point shooting contest not a
time to be honest it's been a little bit
of a whirlwind since we left Charlotte
but you know we're right back in the
swing of things you know can you make
sure to have a scene yesterday for a
quick light practice and then we're just
gearing up for another one today to get
ready for Portland tomorrow how tough
was he for you just to get into the
three-point shooting contest yeah I
didn't actually think I was gonna have
the opportunity to be in it you know at
the end of the day you know you
understand that the NBA is trying to get
you know more marketable guys the
shooting it you know regardless of the
percentage of obviously they're getting
you know good shooters in it but the
all-stars they kind of get the the first
grab at it and you know I know that I
was kind of a last last minute addition
but I mean needless to say I was just
excited to be there and have the
opportunity to shoot I also wonder about
this that even when you're introduced
and I felt bad for you because it didn't
feel like anybody was cheering and I
don't know what it felt like for you but
they're probably going okay who is Joe
Harris you know unless you're really
following the NBA and following the Nets
they probably go who is Joe Harris now
they know you have well what did that
feel like when you got introduced no I
mean it to be honest I didn't even
really notice it I mean there's a buzz
in the arena while you're there you know
everything is happening so quickly
you're not really paying attention to
you know who's get into yours and who's
not obviously you notice the curry
brother is an even Danny Green you know
being from Carolina but I knew going
into it that you know I was probably the
least recognized player that was a part
of it because it was a stacked field you
know pretty much from top to bottom and
yeah I was certainly you know unless
you're a big NBA fan you probably had no
idea who I was
but I'm also thinking that maybe there
was there was less pressure it feels
like there is a normal amount of
pressure but there was less pressure on
you then there was Steph Curry oh
definitely I mean
and Seth are both coming home you know
it's a big big weekend for them just
being back home having the all-star game
in Charlotte for the first time since I
think he was like 91 and and then at the
same time see I was able to go first
which some people were thinking it was a
little bit disadvantage but I thought
you know for me I didn't have to sit and
wait around and kind of get anxious
it's a shoot I just didn't have time to
really think about it I was able to just
go right into it and yeah a lot of those
things kind of all combined you know the
pressure was it probably as high on me
as it was for some of these other guys
and just a little background with Joe
you're from Washington you played for
your father you went to Virginia
graduated you were drafted by the Cavs
and you get drafted by the Cavs that's
the same season LeBron came back to
Cleveland yes yes my rookie year was
LeBrons first year back in Cleveland
okay and then you you end up playing a
little for the Canton charge of the the
the G League what what was what was
different about playing for the Canton
charge like one day for the Canton
charge as opposed to one day for the
Cavs well I think I actually was the
first I guess at the time I was ideally
that's first d-league player to play a
duty game in the morning and then I also
got in in the evening with the Cavs so I
was to get in pretty good experiences on
both ends I mean my experiences with the
with the G Lee were good though
obviously the people that were there and
can't work great a lot of them have
moved up sort of in the ranks you know
coaches GM's people that were there at
the time even some of the players that
were there but obviously you know the
Cavs at that time it was like traveling
around was like you know the Beatles or
something like that I mean it was a
pretty wild experience so LeBron and the
Cavs then you have the Canton charge and
then you're traded to the magic and then
you're immediately waived are you
starting to think about you know what am
I gonna do for a job here what's my
future yeah definitely I mean you know I
I was pretty realistic about the whole
thing I had really proven anything
in the NBA I was a second-round pick you
know not a lot of times do guys sort of
in that scenario get a second
opportunity and then I was just lucky to
get you know get a chance with Brooklyn
where you know Kenny and Shaun marks you
know both saw something to me and like
like the way that I play and how I would
plug into what they were trying to build
here yeah it's been a great great ride
there and you live in Brooklyn uh you
play for the Brooklyn Nets and you got
the Brooklyn beard
I mean you blend in with every other
every other dude in Brooklyn are you who
has the beard longer you or James Harden
Harden for sure this is this is a
somewhat recent addition and beginning
of this year and I just kind of stuck
with dicks I know now if I shave it now
I mean I look like a little kid so I
keep it at least throughout season wait
does this make you look more
intimidating Joe I wouldn't say that I'd
say you know it makes me look a little
more rugged little older which I like
what's the first big purchase that you
made in the NBA I to be honest haven't
really made too many big purchases
really no I mean not a ton has changed I
mean I was pretty pretty simple I mean I
live same spot I mean you know maybe
you're helping out family and friends a
little bit more frequently maybe with
trips vacations nice things like that
but nothing nothing significant are you
the best shooter in Brooklyn uh you know
it might be up for debate but I would
put myself up there okay Reddick lives
in Brooklyn right
I took a point I took a plan hey I kind
of forgot about that but but are you the
bet do you consider yourself the best
shooter I mean you for one night you are
the best three-point shooter in the game
yeah I mean at the same time though I
said it even after I had one you know
just because you know I get a little bit
of luck on my side you know I get hot
Steph cool so I mean stuff made his
first eight or nine and that
championship round thought it was going
to be over for sure but you know by no
means is
our our you know 50 balls that we shied
over to course of two minutes indicative
of who's the best shooter a guy I just
was lucky enough to win that night we
have somebody on my staff one of the
Danites
and he his name his nickname is McLovin
he lives in Brooklyn
he doesn't live too far from you know
the arena he played he played JV at
Dartmouth yep and I was wondering if you
shot NBA threes and he shot highschool
threes yeah would you be up for that
contest that challenge yes McLovin well
I know the spot the Nets practice there
in the preseason it's called pr2 it's
all in the water it's not far from our
side and I kind of own the court so I
don't know if that's an unfair advantage
for you yeah might be I'm sorry you got
the elements on your side too you know
you probably know how to play the wind
and everything that's coming off the
water down there okay yeah you know this
isn't the curry brothers this is a real
challenge Brooklyn style do you think
you could beat McLovin shooting NBA
threes to his high school threes I mean
we might have you just put it to the
test
honestly I don't want to speak out or
too early on this okay but we'll bring
the show down there and you know we'll
settle this the best shooter in Brooklyn
and if you don't want to see if JJ
Redick comes you know in and wants to be
a part of it yeah we could get JJ see if
he wants to be a part of it but he may
not he may not because he might scare
him off yeah he's outside we got to come
up with a nickname for you
but what do you go by I mean I guess my
name in itself is a nickname cuz my real
name is Joseph but your nickname is Joe
man how did you come up with that crazy
nickname Oh my teammates call me buckets
that's what my all my teammates and all
the guys in the Nets call me bucket so
Joey buckets
I also heard beef jerky Joe that was
that was all Richard Jefferson and now
that was more of a rib because he had
told me beforehand
he asked me if I had seen the beef jerky
commercials I didn't know what he was
talking about he likes to get the ones
with the sasquatch he's like you look
exactly like Joey Moses and I think that
people were getting a little like oh
they're stretching out a little bit with
some of them yeah they were stretching
out with some of these nicknames early
on you know Moses didn't have your range
though Moses more of a post player I
think yeah well we will leave that up
for the better when I get into that too
much yeah I know and Joseph of Nazarene
I also saw that one as well that was
pretty funny hey congrats and you know
well maybe we'll set this up in the
offseason I'll send McLovin down there
and he'll shoot high school threes to
your NBA threes
yeah just keep me posted I'll be ready
to go whenever thank you Joe
Joseph congratulations that's Joe Harris
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]